good morning believe nation today's
message is believed in yourself over to
you Robert Johnson I think the first
thing that you can do is it starts with
yourself you have to believe in yourself
if you don't believe in yourself if you
don't believe that you can overcome
obstacles if you don't believe you have
the work ethic if you don't believe you
have the inner confidence to project to
other people it'll never happen because
part of starting a business is not
having not only having the vision of an
idea you've got to build around you a
team of stakeholders who believe in you
people follow leaders people invest in
leaders people support people who have a
vision and are willing to and are able
to articulate it and not just the
ability you know a lot of people could
have got a good gift for gab it's the
ability to convince people that you're
going to be part of something that's
going to be successful you're going to
share in the success it's going to be
beneficial to you and your family in the
long run you're going to be respected
for what you contribute and you're going
to have an opportunity to fulfill your
own dreams consistent with the dreams
the person you're working with if you
can convey that sense of confidence and
that consent because that sense of
leadership and focus on giving people an
opportunity to grow and be successful
with you you're going to have people
enemy really smart people come in to be
a part of what you do this is a great
message and one that I'm sure you expect
to find on my channel and for me believe
is more than just believing in yourself
it's also believe in what you're doing
because you can have all the self
confidence in yourself but if you don't
believe in the product or service that
you're selling then you're not going to
achieve the results
going on so you have to believe not only
yourself but also believe in what you're
doing and then also believe that it's
going to work out and have the courage
and conviction to follow through and
that even if you only see darkness
around you and there's no light anywhere
at the end that tunnel you still believe
that it's going to work out so believe
is a critical message for any
entrepreneur I hope you enjoyed that
message from Robert Johnson and my
question of the day for you today is
what holds you back from believing in
yourself leave it in the comments below
I love to see what you have to say and
I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you for watching continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press 0